hi it's me drew barrymore but maybe you
knew that since you clicked on me like
snl said last season i had a blast in
this studio all by myself but guess what
things are about to change and i'm
looking forward to more togetherness i'm
getting to see all my coworkers and
hopefully you
this suggestion comes from anna who
watches our show all the way from
monterrey mexico
do a whole et themed episode huh
i'm down with that
let's see what do we need for an e.t
themed episode bones plants i mean by
the way i love hearts and flowers and i
don't have to ask myself twice it
clearly came from e.t he had the big red
beating heart which
said he was alive well and happy and
then those flowers were emblematic of
his health and wellness too hearts and
flowers
changed my life so we'll have hearts and
flowers maybe e.t maybe we'll bring up
steven spielberg
see if some other cast members would
show up
but again keep the suggestions coming
anna et also has its 40th anniversary in
2022.
i see some symmetry there
so i think you're totally right that's
gonna actually be perfect a great time
to honor that all right thank you anna
this comes from victoria from san
francisco california
keep your stylist your outfits are
perfect victoria i've actually been
lucky enough to work with none other
than lee harris for over how long has it
been 25 years
that's right
and on our show's instagram you can
actually see our outfit of the day
we have posts and then we show you how
to shop the look so that you can get
something similar for yourself if that's
of interest to you but thank you again
victoria i'm glad you like the look
thank you lee harris
this one comes from lisa who sent us
this suggestion on instagram please
announce that you and adam sandler are
making a new movie well we don't have
any plans to yet but that doesn't mean
that adam will be stopping by on the
show
after all he and i are very near and
dear to each other and we will be
collaborating for the rest of our lives
so
thank you so much for your suggestion um
we've also done a movie every 10 years
and we're probably going to be due for
one soon too so lisa i'm just going to
give you all the credit
for getting us back together and i hope
you like what we do
this one is from tom from toms river new
jersey
coincidence i wonder
have a live audience so i can come in
person we'd love to invite you
tom you're invited i would love for you
to come here to the show when we have an
audience which will be in season two and
we would love to meet you in person so
come on out to new york and come see us
we have a great suggestion from aurelia
who commented on our youtube page maybe
you have a segment where you review the
latest movies shows and books oh
aurelia i love this idea
what if we call it drew's reviews you
know we love to rhyme everything with my
name around here reviews no
that doesn't really work drew's reviews
is probably better but i along with all
of you can review new tv shows upcoming
movies instagram accounts so much stuff
in pop culture let's do this and we
actually worked up two graphics for this
new segment so we'd like to ask you
which one do you guys like better take
the poll because we'd love to get some
of your suggestions for what i should
review and keep those suggestions coming
basically the power is in your hands
i'm excited thank you for the
suggestions let us know what you want
and we will deliver
[Music]